hallo
herzlich willkommen zur sallys welt
heute gibt es wieder ein kleines
grundrezept von mir und zwar weil ich
weiß und dort die us banken mit denen
ihr dann zum beispiel raps oder burritos
machen könnt und es ist wirklich ein
ganz kleines basic grundrezept für das
braucht ihr nur vier zutaten und
deswegen starten wir auch gleich für den
teig brauche ich 400 gramm mehl drei
esslöffel joghurt es 110 gramm 150
milliliter wasser und einen teelöffel
sand jedoch wirklich super schnell
ich meine klar kann man die weißen
ritters auch kaufen aber ihr könnt ihr
auch wirklich ganz schnell zu hause
selber nachmachen
vor allem wenn ihr mal sonntags einfach
lust drauf habt alle läden haben zu und
dann könnte es schnell auspacken
also nehmt es einfach alle zutaten ihr
könnt den teig natürlich auch mit den
händen verkneten
ich habe noch im wasser rein salz und
auch joghurt mit werden die guthaben
ganz kurz zu einem glatten teig
verknetet und dann haben wir eigentlich
schon
jetzt ist der tag schon fertig also nach
nicht einmal zwei minuten und von der
konsistenz her ist wirklich schön weich
aber auch nicht so weit
im türkischen wird man jetzt sagen
quartal sowie ein ohrläppchen weiß oder
ja also wirklich ein schöner
geschmeidiger teig und bei mir werden
das jetzt mittelgroße macias die haben
also etwa 20 cm durchmesser
ihr müsst einfach mal schauen was für
eine pfanne ihr natürlich auch zu hause
habt und daraus bekomme ich jetzt neun
stück und wie geht's immer 75 gramm in
etwa ab
jetzt haben wir die teige zu kleinen
kugeln
jetzt kann der detail gruppen bereits
ausrollen und zwar all ich stets wie
gesagt auf dem durchmesser von 20
zentimetern aus dann nimmt jetzt ein
ganzer mann aus frau starb oder so wie
ich ihn ob so ein türkisches werkzeug
und zwar hat man immer mal auf sein
opfer aber nicht aus dem türkischen
supermarkt sondern auf einem besenstiel
den hat mein papa ihr gemacht einfach
zurecht geschnitten
da war natürlich sauber und damit kann
man jetzt zuerst einmal den teig 16
flachen und dann kriegt man ihn ganz
dünn
indem man ihn aufrollt und dann immer
mit den händen sondern streicht jetzt
immer wieder dreht und dann bleibt auch
schön rot
ich habe jetzt alle parties ausgerollten
habe jetzt bereits eine beschichtete
pfanne auf mittlerer stufe erhitzt ohne
fett und jetzt werden wir darin
ausgepackt und von beiden seiten
und zwar nicht so groß damit sie eben
später auch schön weich werden zum
zusammenrollen also jetzt kurz etwa eine
minute
man sieht es dann auch gleich besteigt
ein bisschen dampf raus und muss jedoch
die farbe verändert sich und dann können
was eigentlich leicht drehen also je
nach dem manchmal sind es nur ein paar
sekunden also ein bisschen farbe
abbekommen
und dann dreht
so wie die etappe auch übrigens dass
laura sport gemacht dass plustert sich
damit auch so auf die zweite seite auch
gut
also nehme ich jetzt raus und verpackt
auch gleich damit schön weich bleibt
jetzt kann ich noch die restlichen
auspacken
jetzt habe ich alle topteams aus
gebacken und sieht darin gelagert also
wichtig ist nur dass ihr sie luftdicht
lagert damit sie eben schön weich
bleiben
die könnte jetzt verwenden um zum
beispiel raps zu machen oder sie kennt
wirklich ganz vieles damit machen raps
machen ihr könnt sie auch einholen und
überbacken ihr könnt auch christian
diers machen
das sind auch so zugeklappt überbackene
also wie gesagt dass nur ein grundrezept
und falls ihr die raps gerne auch name
haben wollt geht auf sadismus blog.de
nochmal die zutaten für euch bis zum
nächsten mal